حوالي 37,000 قتيل النتيجه زلزال تركيا
وسوريا المدمر الامم المتحده تعلن ان
مرحله الانقاذ تقترب من نهايتها
وكشف سر صمود مبنى المهندسين في قهرمان
مرعش هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من
قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
وسط استستمرار عمليات البحث عن ناجين رغم
تضاؤل الامال ارتفعت حصيله ضحايا الزلزال
المدمر الى نحو 37 الف قتيلا في تركيا
وسوريا اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
اعلنت ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال في البلاد
الى اكثر من 31 الفا مشيره الى ان زلزال
دمر اكثر من سته الاف مبدا بشكل كامل فيما
اكد المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان ان عدد
الضحايا في عموم المناطق السوريه بلغ اكثر
من 5300 قتيل لافتا الى ان هذا العدد مرشح
للارتفاع الى اكثر من 7000 بسبب وجود مئات
الجثث التي لا زالت عالقه تحت الانقاض
خلال زيارته الى مدينه حلب السوريه اعلن
منسق الامم المتحده للاغاثه مارتن جرافيث
ان مرحله الانقاذ تقترب من نهايتها وكاله
رويترز نقلت عن قوله ان الحاجه الماسه
ستصبح توفير الملاجئ والطعام والتعليم
والرعايه النفسيه والاجتماعيه للناجين
مشيرا الى انه سمع روايات مؤلمه عن
الكارثه من الناجين في حلب واضاف ان الامم
المتحده ستعمل على نقل المساعدات من مناطق
سيطره الحكومه لمناطق خاضعه لسيطره
المعارضه في الشمال الغربي كما سيتم اطلاق
نداءات لتقديم المساعده لكل المناطق التي
تضررت من الكارثه على حد قوله
[موسيقى]
للنظام السوري بالاستحواذ على المساعدات
الانسانيه كشف المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان ان النظام اشترط مصادره نصف
المساعدات التي تخرج من مناطق الاداره
الذاتيه او الهلال الاحمر الكردي الى ريف
حلب في الوقت ذاته انتشر فيديو لموظفه
المانيه في الهلال الاحمر الكردي
والمتواجده مع قافله المساعدات القادمه من
مناطق شمال شرقي سوريا باتجاه حلب تقول
فيه ان النظام يشترط تسليمه نصف المساعدات
على الاقل للسماح للقافله بالدخول الى
مناطقه وكان مدير البسط رامي عبد الرحمن
اكد العربيه ان مساعدات وصلت من مختلف
الدول العربيه مطالبا بوجود اليه لتوزيعها
الى مستحقها وعدم سرقتها
مع انتشار صور وما مقاطع فيديو للدمار
الذي طالما بين العده في قهرمان مرعش
التركيه والتي تعد مركز الزلزال اثار مبنى
المهندسين المدنيين في المدينه تساؤلات
عده حول سبب عدم انهياره رئيس مجلس اداره
غرفه المهندسين الكهربائيين في تركيا ماهر
اولتاش الذي شارك صوره للمبنى عبر تويتر
ارجع سبب عدم انهيار المبنى الى تاسيسه
السليم وصلابه المواد المستخدمه في بنائه
قائلا حتى في مثل هذه الزلازل الكبيره
هناك مبانئ يمكن ان تصمت طالما اسست ببنيه
سليمان فيما اعلنت السلطات اجراء تحقيق في
كل حالات الاهمال التي ادت الى انهيار
مبادئ في زلزال
وفي خبرنا الاخير وفي ظل استمرار جمع
المساعدات في العديد من دول حول العالم
لمتضرري زلزال اعلنت منصه تيك توك عن
تقديمها مساهمه قدرها 200 الف دولار
لليونيسف لمساعده المتضررين في سوريا
وتركيا بالتزامن مع ذلك وصف الناطق باسم
المنظمه اليونيسف في الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا محمد الحواري الوضع في سوريا
بالماساويه مشددا على حاجه المناطق
المنكوبه لمساعدات عاجله وذكر ان اليونيسف
سجلت حالات لاطفال لم يعد لديهم اقارب على
قيد الحياه
[موسيقى]